la deuxième vague de kobe 19 ne cesse de
faire des dégâts en allemagne et oblige
le gouvernement à réagir après une
réunion virtuelle avec les 16 länder les
états régions allemand la chancelière
angela merkel a annoncé la prolongation
des restrictions jusqu'au 31 janvier
prochain
nous sommes maintenant face à des
situations critiques dans certains
hôpitaux
ce qui signifie que cela nous a
également poussé à adopter des décisions
d'une grande portée aujourd'hui
s'incline de choses se fassent
le 29 décembre l'allemagne a recensé
plus de 1000 morts en 24 heures pour la
première fois depuis le début de la
pandémie dans certaines régions la
situation est critique comme en saxe où
le taux d'incidence de la maladie était
de 323 ce lundi dans les länder les plus
touchés les déplacements seront
fortement limitées
nous avons décidé de prendre des mesures
supplémentaires pour les régions
comptant plus de 200 nouvelles
infections pour 100000 habitants où le
rayon de déplacements doivent être
limités à 15 kilomètres autour du lieu
de résidence avant qu'il n'y ait une
raison valable qui gronde for it tous
les commerces sauf les magasins
d'alimentation et les pharmacies
resteront rideau baissé lors des
prochaines semaines
il en va de même pour les écoles les
parcs ainsi que les lieux culturels qui
ne pourront ouvrir comme prévu le 10
janvier cette extension des contraintes
n'est pas forcément très bien accueillie
au sein de la population allemande
il n'ya pas non plus de perspectives et
nous en avons réellement besoin de toute
urgence au moment de savoir comment les
choses vont continuer en général à un
moment donné voilà ce qu'il manque
il faut dire clairement aujourd'hui et
maintenant que l'espoir que nous avions
lors de la rentrée scolaire que ce
serait une année scolaire plus normal
qu'il serait possible de combler les
retards pris durant l'année scolaire
précédente avec les élèves et pour
enseigner le nouveau programme et pour
mener des examens dans une certaine
mesure
bien sûr cet espoir s'estompe à mesure
que la deuxième vague se prolonge et que
le confinement se poursuit
lors de ses voeux de fin d'année angela
merkel avait annoncé je cite des temps
difficiles pour l'année 2000 21
la deuxième vague de kovy 19 semble loin
de toucher à sa fin sur le sol allemand